[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein name ist was kann fünf jahre lang
berichtete ich als korrespondent aus
china
es war eine spannende aber auch
zermürbende zeit geprägt von einem
ständigen katz und maus spiel mit den
behörden
jetzt will ich dem land eine zweite
chance geben
ich möchte die menschen erleben und
nicht den mächtigen staat
ich will mich mit china versöhnen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
sie packen heute schon alles ein nicht
ganz schön viel
fünf jahre war dies unser zuhause in
shanghai hier wohnte ich zusammen mit
meiner frau und unseren beiden kindern
nach insgesamt 15 jahren in asien ziehen
wir nun zurück in die schweiz
was uns dort erwartet steht noch in den
sternen
[Musik]
eine ungewisse zukunft
was hilft in so einem moment für viele
asiaten ist die antwort auf diese frage
klar
immer wieder habe ich miterlebt das
chinesische bekannte jung oder alt hat
beim wahrsager suchen
[Musik]
ich selbst habe das bisher noch nie
ausprobiert doch jetzt scheint mit der
perfekten moment zu sein
wer weiß vielleicht eröffnet sich mir
dadurch ja ein ganz neues china
[Musik]
im korrespondentenbüro in shanghai
beginne ich mit der recherche zusammen
mit meinem regisseur dave der aus der
schweiz angereist ist
aber du er hofft jetzt nicht wirklich
erkenntnisse wird ein leben oder denkst
du das könnte doch was bringen
also ich glaube ich glaube nicht daran
aber es kann tatsächlich seien und dass
deswegen möchte ich mich auf dieses
experiment einlassen dass da eine person
ist die irgendwelche fragen dann spricht
an die ich vielleicht vielleicht nicht
selber gedacht habe aber die ich
unterdrücke oder so wenn so viele leute
in ähnlichen situationen wie ich jetzt
bin das machen dann kann es ja sein dass
das bei dem einen oder anderen auch
wirklich etwas gebracht hat
doch wo anfangen mit dass woche durch
einen technischen trick haben wir hier
im büro zugriff auf google
normalerweise ist der zugang in china
gesperrt deshalb finden wir auch nur
einträge von westlichen touristen
tirolerin tiffany pattinson sticht
sofort ins auge
also ich schreibe dir jetzt mal an ich
kontaktiere sie per widget der
chinesischen app für alles kannst du mal
auch bei durchsuchen
meine assistentin und dolmetscherin
tieren wird in der chinesischen
suchmaschine fündig ein traditioneller
wahrsager gut bewertet nicht weit von
hier
ich glaube es ist hier ja
ich denke du solltest vorausgehen und
bescheid sagen dass unser team gleich
kommt
es wäre unhöflich wenn ihr einfach so
auftauchen bis gleich
ja ich werde krank oder ein kind von mir
wir krank oder sowas
das würde mich jetzt schon beschäftigen
obwohl ich eigentlich ja nicht daran
glaube es gibt so was wie selbst
erfüllende prophezeiung und wenn man
sagt wenn das mal ausgesprochen ist
irgendwie beschäftigt sagen mir dann
doch sie kommt anscheinend braucht man
einen termin und bis donnerstag gibt es
keine
er ist voll ausgebucht ja voll
ausgebucht doch zu früh gefreut
unser fahrer justine hat mitbekommen was
wir suchen er schlägt uns vor seinen
persönlichen von schwimmmeister zu
besuchen
du kennst ihn persönlich ja ich kenne
ihn seit fünf jahren
unser büro ist damals umgezogen und er
hat geholfen die möbel zu platzieren
schwer wird hier nicht nur auf möbel
angewandt über 5000 kontakte beim ipad
[Gelächter]
beim feng shui geht es um positive
energie mann leitet die energie um sich
damit aufzuladen
hier ist süden da ist zieht wespen und
dort ist nordwest ich bin 1948 geboren
deshalb ist diese position gut für mich
deshalb steht sein bürostuhl dort so
sieht also ein büro aus dass komplett
nach fünf schwierig linien eingerichtet
wurde
leider ist es meist der erste eindruck
der einem im gedächtnis bleibt
der mann den ich als mensch eigentlich
sehr sehr sympathisch waren aber wenn
ich mir vorstelle dass der mein haus
oder eine wohnung einrichten würde
dann ist dir geboren ich weiß ja hier
ist es um 21 14
alle meine daten landen in einer fünf
schwer haben sie kein problem damit dass
ihr beruf sehr traditionell ist sie aber
diese moderne technik nutzen ist das
nicht ein widerspruch
es ist einfach bequemer die
interpretation ist gleich wie früher
das ist die kunst anfangs schwer gibt es
fünf elemente erde wasser feuer luft und
metallen aus deren verhältnis werden
meine acht buchstaben errechnet mit
überraschendem ergebnis
ich sehe eine 40 blume du wirst viele
frauen haben
[Gelächter]
man kann meister weißer kranich zu rate
ziehen wenn man einen namen für das kind
sucht ein datum für die hochzeit oder
wie ich eine generelle beratung möchte
alles streng nach preisliste
ich weiß immer noch nicht das ende des
jahres brauche ich einen neuen job
im moment arbeite ich hier als
korrespondent aber dieser job endet mit
dieser doku serie und ich weiß noch
nicht was ich danach mache wenn ich
zurück in der schweiz
das gesundheitswesen wäre gut für dich
denn gesundheit wird metall zugeordnet
früher hatte er kein metall aber jetzt
schon das wirtschafts- und finanzwesen
maschinenbau und automobilbranche wären
auch nicht schlecht
wenn es etwas gibt was ich niemals
machen würde ist finanzindustrie oder
automobilindustrie das licht nicht total
fern ich kann mir aber ganz gut erklären
warum man draufgekommen ist bereit sonst
auch ganz viele ausländer deutsche und
so weiter in shanghai und ein ganz
großer teil von denen arbeiter genau in
der finanz- oder in der autoindustrie
und ich glaube das haben wir einfach
angenommen dass ich auch dazu guter rat
ist teuer
200 euro wechsel per widget den besitzer
nett war ja doch ich will mehr wissen
ich habe mich mit maja verabredet bei
einer sinologin aus deutschland die seit
über zehn jahren hier lebt und sich
auskennt mit chinesischer spiritualität
also dieses ganze feld wahrsagerei das
gehört ja in den bereich der
traditionellen chinesischen kultur und
religion und ich glaube dass vielfach
von vornherein geständnis barrieren da
sind für uns als westler weil natürlich
überhaupt grundsätzlich die religion im
westen und im osten so muss man es
wahrscheinlich sagen sich so wahnsinnig
unterscheidet meyer wir uns einführen in
die religiöse welt von china
sie bringt uns zu einem drastischen und
einem buddhistischen tempel chinesen
sind häufig nicht anhänger auf einer
bestimmten religion
ein sprichwort sagt ein chinese ist
konfus wenn es ihm gut geht
als da ist wenn es ihm schlecht geht und
als protest im angesicht des todes nur
zehn gehminuten entfernt von meinem büro
liegt der pompöse czingon tempel kommt
uns ja komisch vorne als christen wenn
man jetzt in einem
den tempel einer anderen religion geht
und dort sich vor der götter statue vor
dem mutterbild herbig aber in ganz asien
wird es einfach nur als ein zeichen des
respekts gesehen es gibt keine
gottesdienste sondern wenn du ein
anliegen hasst man irgendwas ist dann
gehst du hier hin und bringst deine
opfergabe spricht so entstünden bei
rauch oder die spende ist ein bisschen
geld es ist mein erster besuch bisher
hinter diesen tempel hauptsächlich für
eine touristenattraktion
das ist das was ich kenne es mit wie z
probier's mal
analoge räucherstäbchen digital bezahlt
heute sind es zwischen beide hände und
verbeugt sich dreimal in jede
himmelsrichtung
etwas seltsam fühlte sich schon an
doch den gedanken dass er jeder
willkommen ist finde ich durchaus
sympathisch
das zentrum des tempels bildet eine
riesige buddha statuen der buddhismus
kam vor über 2000 jahren aus indien
china rund 100 millionen anhänger soll
es hier geben die uhr chinesische
religion ist aber der dow es muss ein
viel glauben die meisten anhänger hat
jedoch der sogenannte chinesische
volksglaube er setzt sich zusammen aus
buddhismus taoismus konfuzianismus dem
ahnenkult und anderen traditionellen
bräuchen am eingang des weißen wolken
tempels begrüßt uns ein wahrsager du
bist im ausland geboren und dadurch kann
er für dich kann er dir nicht deinen
roßkopf erstellen so dass interessante
den er kurz überlegt ob es eventuell
eine ausrede
ja natürlich auch mal muss man immer mit
einberechnen alle tempel sind einer
staatlichen religionsbehörde unterstellt
und dann wäre es bei mir immer so dass
automatisch wenn er hätte jemand kommt
und sagt ja es geht jetzt leider nicht
der herr ist aus dem ausland dann könnte
das auch heißen dass dem moment jetzt
vielleicht gerade die sind wahrsager das
einfach insgesamt zu heiß ist
religion ist in china ein heikles thema
nach 1966 zu zeiten der kommunistischen
kulturrevolution war sie komplett
verboten erst seit ende der 70er jahre
herrscht wieder religionsfreiheit
eigentlich denn seit 2013 ist präsident
jean ping an der macht und unter ihm
lautet die oberste parole semi sierung
jegliche lehre muss partei konform sein
[Musik]
wir haben glück und erleben eine
taoistische zeremonie
privatpersonen bestellen beim tempel
einen termin dann verfeuern sie papier
autos häuser und spielgeld in der
hoffnung auf wohlstand
und das geht eben auch eine wahrsagerei
indes muss die wahrsagerei ist
angesiedelt im davis muss die ganzen
verschiedenen formen der wahrsagerei sei
da oben eigentlich über astrologie sei
dass über vom mds muss wie auch beim
feng shui spielt dass die lebensenergie
eine zentrale rolle
nach touristische vorstellung ist sie
der ursprung der welt in fünf schwer
geht es darum eben diese energie positiv
zu lenken
siehst du ja das ist sie das ist sie ja
hier
wir haben uns von maja verabschiedet und
ich warte gespannt auf die nächste
erfahrung tirolerin tiffany pattinson
die wir bei google gefunden haben
caro ist eigentlich eher eine westliche
methode momentan aber sehr beliebt bei
jungen chinesen richten wir uns da
drüben ist nicht das erste mal dass so
etwas hier machst nein das ist meine
übliche ort war wirklich ja wie hast du
das gelernt das ist eine lustige
geschichte
ich wurde in der schule gehänselt und
niemand wollte mit mir sprechen
ich dachte das war eine coole art
freunde zu finden
dann traf ich diese sehr wichtige frage
sie brachte mir die grundlagen bei
seither ist das erfahrung wie er ist
kann ich das nehmen was du mir gleich
selbst ich denke das hängt von dir ab
ich habe konnten die nehmen es sehr
ernst sie verlassen das land wegen
meiner weissagung sie treffen beziehungs
entscheidung mit heiraten auf grundlage
meiner lesung andere stellen einfach
fragen und nehmen es mehr als sprach
eine meiner größten fragen habe ich weil
mein leben sich bald rapide ändert ich
war 15 jahre hier in asien fünf davon in
china
und jetzt sehe ich zurück in die schweiz
was erwartet mich wie soll ich mich
darauf vorbereiten
[Musik]
ok benutze deine linke hand und nie
meine karte dann gibt sie mir das
repräsentieren was ich hier zuerst ja
ist was dich antreibt du liebst es zu
reichen
es gibt drei orte didier vorspielen du
denkst du hättest entschieden zurück zu
gehen
du bist ja aber nicht sicher ob das
tatsächlich schon da ein endgültiges
ziel sein soll ja musste schmunzeln hat
das gesagt habe
das ist natürlich das was
mein umfeld auch befürchtet da in einem
tiefen inneren weiß ich schon dass mir
die schweiz vielleicht schnell zeigen
werden wird die sache ist die ich will
china im guten verlassen
doch ich bin journalist und habe die
ganzen jahre über viel negatives
berichtet jetzt will ich meinen inneren
frieden mit china
also das bist du das ist es symbolisiert
augenmaß das auf dem kopf steht
das bedeutet bezogen auf china wenn wir
es mal als person betrachten dass es
sich ungerecht behandelt fühlt es fühlt
sich als wäre es ungenügend beschrieben
worden
da gibt es noch etwas zu tun und diese
beiden karten erklären die erste
bedeutet du sollst beziehungen pflegen
partnerschaften und freundschaften die
zweite karte bedeutet reisen viele
reisen
zusammenfassend könnte man sagen es geht
darum beziehungen mit einheimischen
aufzubauen
das könnte etwas sein warum du dich noch
kümmern sollte
da hat sie auch wirklich an einen wunden
punkt getroffen
was ich nach wie vor wahnsinnig
schwierig finde hat wirklich
freundschaften zu schließen über die
kulturbrücke sich kultur graben hinaus
diese brücke zu bauen
ja ich meine natürlich ich kann es mir
nur so erklären dass ich zu wenig
investiert haben ist aber auch durch
meinen job bedingt recht schwierig weil
ich einfach ganz auf nicht da bin oft
absagen muss man nicht kurzfristig
irgendwo hin muss
da hat sie absolut recht also dass das
müsste eigentlich möglich sein müsste
mehr sein
natürlich glaube ich nicht dass man mit
kartenlegen oder handlesen in die
zukunft schauen kann
aber es war ein überraschend gutes
gespräch
vielleicht vielleicht tatsächlich das
eine ist sicher die erfahrung aber das
andere ist auch einfach charisma ist
vielleicht tatsächlich auch irgendwie
ein weib der hat zwischen mann und frau
oder irgendwie die weibliche kraft die
sie da nutzt auch die später garantiert
auch mit
[Musik]
ich verlasse shanghai und reise dorthin
wo chinesische spiritualität noch am
authentischsten sein soll
nach taiwan oder wie es offiziell heißt
in die republik china das verhältnis
zwischen taiwan und china ist
kompliziert bis 1949 waren taiwan und
china 1 dann rief mao zedong die
kommunistische volksrepublik aus seine
gegner flüchteten auf die insel taiwan
bis heute betrachtet sich taiwan als
unabhängig
[Musik]
während mai auf dem festland die
religion unterdrückte durfte man in
taiwan die spiritualität stets leben ein
drittel der rund 24 millionen taiwan
esens entlasten und die wahrsagerei ist
hier absolut alltäglich
um diesen termin verspreche ich mir
einiges wir haben eine audienz bei star
wahrsager juvantia vorstand des
taiwanesischen wahrsager verbandes
menschen berät die höchsten politiker
und stars des landes und das schon in
zweiter generation
egal das ist mein vater einfach alle die
berühmten leute die schon zu seinem
vater gegangen sind das ist als er
gestorben ist wer da alles quasi dies
dass das begräbnis mit organisierter und
wenn damals schon die höchsten leute der
regierung dabei glaube es geht ihm jetzt
darum das klar zu machen wie wichtig das
ist vom lionsclub vor dort bin ich
präsident gibt noch viel papier her
zeitung keine jüngere schwester hatte
eine hohe stellung bei der regierung
das bin ich mit dem polizeichef
es kommen also viele wichtige politiker
zu ihnen und stellen ihn und fragen
wichtige fragen
das heißt sie haben auch viel einfluss
auf die politik
ich sage immer alles ganz aufrichtig und
gewissenhaft das ist die berühmte
entertainer
es ist eine große verantwortung oder
auch fürs land das ist
die lage auch zu entkommen und er sagt
nachdem uns wirklich jede persönlichkeit
präsentiert wurde die diese heiligen
hallen je beehrt hat kommen wir
tatsächlich noch zu meinem anliegen
jemand hat mir gesagt dass ich nicht in
der schweiz bleiben werde
ich würde maximal zwei jahre dort
bleiben und dann wieder weg sein
was sagt er dazu zieht er das auch so
werde ich ganz zurückgehen so wie du
bist war es seltsam wenn du kein geld
machen
du wirst dorthin gehen wo der meiste
profit wartet wohl mich geld machen kann
wenn ich hingehen
also wenn ich in der schweiz kein geld
mache werde ich in ein anderes land
gehen ok tipps die sich hauptsächlich um
den schnöden mammon reden und ratschläge
die wohl jeder einem mitte 40 jährigen
geben würde und dazu noch ein zwei
treffer bei der beschreibung meines
charakters dann ist die exklusive
beratung auch schon vorbei
[Musik]
ich glaube das ist die frage haben wir
habe ich mir lange aufgestellt er ist
sehr offensichtlich auch der präsident
des lions-clubs da also der ist ein sehr
angesehener mann offensichtlich auch
sehr gut vernetzt und ich glaube das ist
etwas was in china hat in der
chinesischen kultur enorm wichtig ist
ist so genannte krankheit mann dem das
beziehungsnetz und wenn man in diesem
beziehungsnetz hoch oben ist ich das
stellt auch niemand mehr etwas in frage
das darf man nicht das ist eine
hierarchiestufe die man erreicht hat
da geht man einfach nur schon hin weil
man weiß dass chef geht auch dahin mein
freund geht auch dahin
da muss gut sein mein bedarf an
wahrsager und ist fürs erste gedeckt mir
steht der sinn nach wissenschaft
sie besuchen professor heyo er ist einer
der berühmtesten soziologen des landes
und experte für wahrsagerei sie sind
immer falsch sie bescheissen immer ich
habe darüber geschrieben ich habe acht
oder neun von ihnen interview was macht
einen wahrsager zu einem guten oder
schlechten wahrsager gibt es da
unterschiede
oder ist der eine einfach ein besserer
betrüger der bessere betrüger warum
glauben die leute denn daran wenn es so
offensichtlich war saga oder astrologen
sagen immer etwas ambivalentes das kann
mal richtig sein und mal falsch wenn sie
richtig liegen glaubt man es gern liegen
sie falsch sagt man vielleicht beim
nächsten mal wenn man das gesamte
anschaut ist der effekt eher positiv als
negativ
sonst würde eine gesellschaft nicht
erlauben dass es sie gibt sie haben
negative und man kann sagen dass weil
die leute an astrologie wahrsager oder
volksreligion glauben die gesellschaft
so stabil
weniger chaotisch sie erhalten die
soziale ordnung
andererseits denke ich das ist nicht gut
weil die leute ein falsches wissen
glauben sie handeln nicht rational
enttäuscht ich bin nicht enttäuscht ich
meine das ist wie gesagt es gibt einen
grund dass ich das bis jetzt in meinem
leben
dass das nicht stattgefunden hat weil
ich eben auch genau das glauben was der
professor sagt also ich bin nach wie vor
interessiert ist das herauszufinden ist
wie das hier funktioniert aber ich fand
das jetzt auch spannend zu hören dass
die hälfte aller taiwanesen geht in
ihrem geburtsjahr einmal zum tempel um
sich das geburts sternzeichen segnen zu
lassen also das schon etwas was
offensichtlich sehr tief verankert ist
12 tier sternzeichen gibt es im
chinesischen horoskop
diese beziehen sich aber nicht auf
monate sondern auf jahre
ich zum beispiel bin im jahr des hasen
geboren jetzt ist das jahr der ratte
doch alle zwölf jahre kommt der hase an
die reihe
aber das jahr in dem man geboren ist
bringt an kein glück im gegenteil es
birgt risiken
theoretisch müsste ich dann zum tempel
gehen und die götter milde stimmen
das ist der affe die ziege und wo es
meins das schöne an taiwan ist die
freundlichkeit selbst wenn man ohne
voranmeldung und laufender kamera einen
riesigen tempel betritt weiß er welche
eigenschaften der hase hat hilft ruhig
rein elegant und er hat das potenzial zu
ewigem leben so dachte ich zumindest bis
zur befragung de
was bedeutet der umzug zurück in die
schweiz für meine familie um das
herauszufinden muss ich 100 stückchen
solange fallen lassen bis eines
herausragt um diesen hier der ragt
besonders heraus die nun erzählen
jetzt muss sich die götter fragen ob es
auch wirklich die richtige nummer für
mich ist in der schublade mit der nummer
10 steht die antwort auf meine frage um
sie zu verstehen braucht man einen
fachmann und ein übersetzungs buch ich
habe nach der familie gefragt
[Musik]
doppelt runter aber hochgehen
unvorhersehbares pech untereinander
du solltest meditieren sollte meditieren
sind ein ort um die gad am schutz zu
bieten
also ich habe tatsächlich mit meiner
frau telefoniert jetzt in den tagen hier
und habe das auch erzählt dass das
rausgekommen ist
so überraschend war überrascht war sie
nicht derweil natürlich kommt eine
schwierige zeit jetzt auch auf uns zu
haben einen kompletten neuanfang der
schweiz unsere kinder müssen eingeschult
werden neu dass für alle für uns alle
wir wissen nicht recht wie es weitergeht
kommen 99 wohnhaus das wird nicht das
schöne an asien ist dass das schicksal
nichts unumstößliches ist es gibt immer
mittel und wege dies zu ändern
meditieren guido milde stimmen oder die
x zu stark wir besuchen zurzeit wird sie
durch die stadt fortan getragen das
größte spirituelle event taiwans acht
tage pilgern tausende hals suchende der
maßstab war hinterher
die wasser göttin ist die wichtigste
touristische göttin taiwans und soll
glück bringen
am meisten glück bringt es wenn du es
schaffst unsere die statue zu kriechen
und dort bietet
was sie tun aus
der vendée tempel ist einer von rund 100
tempeln an denen die marge auf ihrem 400
km langen marsch halt macht
[Musik]
gläubige kommen nicht nur aus taiwan
viele reisen extra aus der volksrepublik
china an
für jeden mit gebildeten tempel gibt es
einen gelben lauf pendeln
für ihr glück bringen die pilger opfer
aller art
um wie im bund djb
wann die wasser gehört den herankommt
kann uns niemand genau sagen
vor dem tempel fährt dieser lastwagen an
uns vorbei man sagt uns darauf würden
die marge träger transportiert die hier
auf ihre nächste schicht warten
schaut mal die füße
noch machen sie das um die marge zu
ehren das bringt glück
das ist die masse in echtzeit das ist
die orten zeigt in echtzeit
wir sind hier nördlich von rio
wir beschließen der start wer hingegen
zu gehen
all diese opfer gaben
[Musik]
vor jedem haus bereiten sich die
menschen auf die marge statt
und verschenken selbst zubereitetes
essen
das ticket ist eigentlich manchmal ist
es manchmal auch nicht
[Gelächter]
dann finden wir die wasserköpfe ihnen
warteschlange denkst du es wird klappen
bekommt jeder eine chance ich denke wenn
man in der schlange ist schon
hinderung treffen wir eine familie die
schon gestern vergeblich gewartet hat
geht ihr alle zusammen
er geht mit ihr er nimmt sie auf den arm
schaut mal sie sind bald sah
das bedeutet dort die statue
was meint ihr wisst gar nichts also wenn
wir in der kolonne sind sagt er
eigentlich jetzt die chance in 90% das
mannschaft aber gestern so dass sie
irgendwann abgebrochen haben preis zu
lange gedauert hat
was sie dann weiter musste die leute
drängen
[Musik]
und dann kommt plötzlich bewegung in die
sache
[Musik]
sie lassen niemanden mehr darunter
ist doch wohl nicht schon zu ende
da kommt nichts mehr also haben wir es
auch passt
jan o nein wir haben sie nicht verpasst
aber so wird es aussehen jetzt werden
wir etwas nervös
sie muss größer sein als das
seid vorsichtig es kann sehr eng und
chaotisch werden immer zu zweit
[Musik]
alle 1
hallo
dollar
mahu sehr schön
ja ist ein riesenunterschied was da
emotional abgeht jetzt zu den wahrsagern
unseren sachen zu den tempel die wir in
shanghai angeschaut haben das hat mich
jetzt wirklich mitgenommen
ich hab mein herz in technik club
[Musik]
sehen kann man die wassergüte ihn nicht
doch irgendwie schafft sie es
tatsächlich alle glücklich zu machen
[Musik]
einen versuch will ich noch unternehmen
um auch einen wahrsager zu finden der
mich derart berührt
deshalb reisen wir weiter nach hongkong
die chinesische sonderverwaltungszone
wurde 1997 von den briten an china
zurückgegeben
spiritualität wird hier auch heute noch
viel offener gelebt als in der
volksrepublik
in der skyline tobt sogar ein
regelrechter 5w krieg
nur eines von vielen beispielen ist die
bank of china als sie gebaut wurde
liefen die geschäfte der umliegenden
banken schlagartig schlechter
der grund war die dreieckige form der
fassade das gebäude zerschnitt das gute
fang schwer und strahlte negative
energie auf die umliegenden häuser
die ages bc bankwerte sich auf ihrem
dach wurden zwei kleine in kanonen form
installiert sie schossen die schlechte
energie zurück und prompt liefen die
geschäfte wieder besser
in hongkong ist spirituelles wirklich
allgegenwärtig man muss nur den
geräuschen folgen
sie sagt es war nicht leicht beim bösen
geist raus zu klopfen
du solltest also aufpassen
wie werdet ihr das pech raus dieses buch
hilft gegen 100 arten von pech
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt musst du deinen namen sehen
basta
moskau
[Musik]
hongkong scheint mir tatsächlich der
perfekte ort zu sein um einen
überzeugenden wahrsager zu finden
mein geheimtipp praktiziert in einem
einkaufszentrum aufs ambiente kommt es
ja nicht an
in hongkong spricht man kantonesisch
nicht man darin
deshalb begleitet mich hier die
hongkonger intern sprechen sie
eigentlich natürlich dem motto scheint
es genau zu nehmen mein geburtsdatum
rechnet er erst einmal um zuerst
konvertieren wir es in den chinesischen
kalender in deinem geburtsdatum gibt es
vier sehr wichtige informationen
tanja hat zwei elemente dein monate zwei
elemente dein tag aber zwei elemente und
eine stunde zwei elemente diese acht
elemente komponieren dein schicksal
mir gefällt dass er alles anschaulich
erklärt es ist ein jahr feier
du kennst doch lang feuer steht für die
sonne
deshalb sind young feuer personen
üblicherweise waren und enthusiastisch
wie die sonne doch es gibt eine
kehrseite lang feuer menschen haben ein
hitziges gemüt das holz feuer und wasser
metall führt was ist metall und das ist
geld du weißt dass schon deshalb bist du
kein geschäftsmann wenn du geschäfte
machen musst wird es dir langweilig wir
können auch beziehungen zu anderen
menschen erkennen zb deine eltern sind
holz holz unterstützt ein feuer
sie haben sich viel um mich gekümmert
als der junge warst hattest du deshalb
keine gute zeit
gefühltes dich eingeengt durch ihre
fürsorge
ich habe mich in der kindheit von meinen
eltern tatsächlich manchmal ein gegend
geführt allerdings wenn ich heute
zurückschaue wo ich selber vater von
zwei kindern finde ich meine eltern
haben das ganz gut gemacht also ich war
glaube ich auch einfach an und klingt
das sehr viel freiheit zu machte sie
haben sich jetzt sehr auf die
vergangenheit konzentrieren
sie schauen nicht so sehr in die zukunft
ist das zu hypothetisch die
vergangenheit ist natürlich wichtig wir
müssen bestätigen dass die vergangenheit
stimmt dann können wir zur zukunft
kommen beispielsweise im jahr 2017 da
gab es viele konflikte und dann ab 2018
hattest du viel glück im beruf 2018 war
tatsächlich das beste jahr für mich als
journalist in china
ich fühlte mich am stärksten das stimmt
absolut und 2017 hatte ich wirklich viel
mühe und weil sich jetzt die elemente
ändern gehst du zurück in den westen
die elemente ändern sich zu metall und
wasser metall bedeutet auch westen
wie kommt es eigentlich dass der
chinesische kalender anscheinend mehr
aussagt als der westliche kalender das
ist ein großes mysterium
niemand weiß dass es heißt dieser
kalender wurde 2006 100 vor christus
erschaffen vom gelben kaiser aber wie
konnte er so einen klugen kalender
erstellen
woher sollen wir das wissen es könnten
aliens gewesen sei
[Musik]
heute war es schon zum teil entlarven
es war halt einfach überzeugen dass er
sachen gesagt hat wirklich aus meiner
vergangenheit relativ konkret an jahre
gebunden an den abschnitt in meinem
leben gefunden
die tatsächlich jetzt wirklich gestimmt
haben zum ersten mal hatte ich nicht das
gefühl okay da kann irgendwie was dran
sein
[Musik]
beflügelt von dieser wirklich besonderen
begegnung plane ich für morgen ein
kleines experiment
doch nicht ohne vorbereitung
was möchtest du fragen
ich würde gerne wissen morgen ein guter
tag für mich ist um nach macau ins
kasino zu gehen
ja
dollar
ballaballa
was hat er für ein sternzeichen meint
ihr ist der hase
[Gelächter]
es ist sehr asiatisch sich von guter
energie einfach treiben zu lassen und
gerade habe ich ein gutes gefühl denn
macau ist nach unserer freundin der
wasser göttinger zu benannt
[Musik]
eine stunde dauert die überfahrt ins
spielparadies wie hongkong ist auch
macao chinesische sonderverwaltungszone
im gegensatz zum festland ist hier
glücksspiel erlaubt die casinos machen
deutlich mehr umsatz als diejenigen in
las vegas
alles auf die neuen sitze ich im grand
lisboa einem der ältesten casinos in der
schnell wachsenden stadt mein budget
beträgt 1000 hongkong dollar rund 110
euro gewechselt in zehn spieltipps
die zwölf nicht die neuen so läuft es
acht runden lang
doch dann habe ich eine eingebung
[Musik]
1640 sind deine glückszahlen die letzten
beiden chips also auf 1 und 4 und 6 und
die pech zahl 13 da könnte man fast
abergläubisch werden
es ist schon faszinierend was diese
wahrsagerei bewirkt ich bin absolut kein
spieler und doch hätte ich insgeheim
darauf gehofft dass die neuen
tatsächlich fällt für mich hatte sich
definitiv gelohnt mich auf das
experiment wahrsagerei einzulassen
ich glaube immer noch nicht dass sie als
instrument der prophezeiung funktioniert
doch als eine art gesprächstherapie kann
sie durchaus nützlich sein
mehr zumindest wurden einige wertvolle
hinweise gegeben die zwar vor mir lagen
die ich aber nicht so klar gesehen habe
mehr zeit für die familie
meditieren und die chinesische kultur
ohne journalistische scheuklappen
betrachten
freundschaften schließen bevor ich das
land endgültig verlassen
genau damit fange ich jetzt an
[Musik]